now going back aways I read that your
first published work was a key a letter
to Stan Lee and Jack Kirby now the comic
book readers Fantastic Four number 20
yes praising the contents of Fantastic
Four number 17 I think it I said
something along the lines of Shakespeare
move over Stanley has arrived
I also unfortunately use the phrase in a
letter by gumbo which was fine until
some other kids in my high school
discovered a letter and I was tormented
with by gumbo for the entire remainder
of that sophomore year in high school or
whatever it was so if you're gonna write
a letter to a comic book don't use the
phrase by gumbo it's a it'll just get
you a lot of humiliation
how many novelists are influenced by
comics I mean Jonathan Lethem Marlon
James the list goes on but what about
comics in my crochet bomb right The
Adventures of Kavalier and clay um but
what about comics influences you as a
writer today and can we see the
influence of comics that the early early
comes on you're working what are some of
your favorite comics today you know I
was a obsessive I was one of the guys
who was right there too beginning of
comics fandom being formed in the early
60s and in addition to letters in the
comic magazine I also wrote amateur
comic book stories about my own heroes
and in little amateur fanzines so I I
was certainly part of it and I collected
all the comics I don't follow comics as
closely today partly because I'm really
tired of reboots and and retcons and all
these things where they go back and mess
with the continuity it's always seem to
me to be sort of a violation of the
unspoken contract between reader and
writer when they when they start doing
that you know you read a comic for 10
years and then they say oh we're
starting it all over again and none of
those stories that you read happened
actually happened I knew they didn't
actually happen but still they were you
know that was part of that I was really
well spider-man
this doesn't happen in spider-man now
this stuff didn't happen to spider-man
that it's a cheat I hated them so I
don't follow a lot of a lot of comics
today but well as an old-school comic
computers what do you think of all these
comic book movies it seems you a lot of
reboots and rehashing and retellings on
the big screen you know I enjoy some of
them but they did again you know I
thought the first you know the Sam
Raimi's to spider-man movies with Tobey
Maguire were great the first two the
third was kind of a mess but then they
rebooted the whole thing that wasn't
necessary let's just go ahead with
spider-man 4 and way what the hell do we
have to go back and tell the origin
again and all that so yeah so even there
I don't like these reboots and restarts
I mean you asked about influences this
was pointed out to me I had a number of
letters in the Marvel Comics of the
early 60s not only the one you
referenced the first one that Fantastic
Four but I had one in Avengers issue
where I was praising a previous Avengers
issue the one that introduced a
character of Wonder Man now Wonder Man
for those of you who are not up on the
Avengers comics in the 1960s Wonder Man
was this new character who had appeared
and he joined the Avengers he was very
powerful but he wasn't really a hero he
was really a villain who had been
created by one of the avengers foes to
destroy the Avengers from within so you
know he could become a member and he
could betray them but he joined them and
he got to know them and he liked them
and when the moment came that he should
have betrayed them to their deaths he
wasn't able to do it and instead he went
over to the heroic side and died and I
love this story it was it was a great I
thought it's a such a terrific story and
I look back at it now and I see it's all
over my work I'd say you know here's a
hero there's a great hero who appears
and then immediately dies here's a great
character he's a hero but really he's a
villain because he's got a secret but
then when it comes time for him to do
something villainous he's he redeems
himself by doing something heroic
instead I love great characters I love
unexpected twists I love
characters who died they did later mess
it up by bringing Wonder Man back as
they do in comic books but you know I
don't make that mistake with most of my
characters they they usually stay pretty
dead but I look at that and I say huh oh
my god I read that thing when I was like
13 years old and then 14 years old and I
really corrupted me for a life and of
course you write fantasy and you know
that but you've had a long career I'm
reading your work in Omni and analog and
the you you had a science fiction story
called with morning called miss fall an
award-winning short story science
fiction award losing story it was
nominated for all the major awards but
it lost all of them I have a long
history of losing a story right answers
always they have to have answers but the
questions are so much finer now in the
world of Ice and Fire
it's interesting you write it like a
real history book in that some questions
are left unanswered sources contradict
each other why did you decide to leave
so many answers out so many questions
unanswered in the book and have so much
contradiction is there a joy in that for
you do you have the real answers in your
head somewhere I you know as you say I
was trying to replicate a real history
book you know when when I when I read
about some of the sources I've drawn on
the Wars of the Roses or the Hundred
Years War or you know the histories of
Scotland or England or France you know
you you come across these wonderful
stories and then later you come across
with all the historians said no no that
story was in later fabrication none of
it is true and and inevitably the story
is so much better than the the boring
version that the more distinguished
modern historian is putting on you so
you know I wanted to have the wonderful
stories in but also had that little
touch of realism by having people argue
about well is it true or isn't true
exactly how does
you know there's that famous quote from
the man who shot Liberty valance you
know when when truth and legend disagree
print the legend
so I print a legend but I you know hedge
my bets a little so but that's that's
been fun